>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT" ."
BRETT KAVANAUGH JUST FINISHED
SPEAKING WITH MARTHA MacCALLUM
AND HE PUSHED BACK AND DENIED
COMPLETELY ALL OF THE ALEX
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST HIM.
IN DOING THAT HE HAD TIMES
PROVIDED A LEVEL OF INFORMATION
ABOUT HIS PERSONAL LIFE THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN THINKABLE JUST
DAYS AGO.
>> Martha: THROUGH ALL THESE
YEARS IN QUESTION, YOU WERE A?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
>> SO NEVER HAD INTERCOURSE WITH
ANYONE IN HIGH SCHOOL AND
COLLEGE SINCE WE ARE PROBING
INTO THAT?
>> MANY YEARS AFTER, I WILL
LEAVE IT AT THAT.
>> Tucker: NOT YOUR
CONVENTIONAL INTERVIEW.
HE WAS ASKED REPEATEDLY ABOUT
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST HIM AND HIS
WIFE SAT BY HIM AS HE DENIED ALL
OF THEM.
>> ARE NOT TO LET FALLS
ACCUSATIONS DRIVE US OUT OF THIS
PROCESS.
WE ARE LOOKING FOR A FAIR
PROCESS WHERE YOU CAN HEAR MY
LIFELONG RECORD.
>> Tucker: NOBODY EXPECTED
ANYTHING LIKE THIS WHEN THAT
CONFIRMATION PROCESS STARTED.
WE WILL HAVE MORE FROM MARTHA'S
INTERVIEW AND MARTHA WILL JOIN
US ON THE SET LATER ON TO TELL
US WHAT IT WAS LIKE IN THAT
ROOM.
BUT WE TYPICALLY OPEN THIS HOUR
BY TALKING WITH SOMEONE THAT WE
DISAGREE WITH.
WE AGREE WITH STRAIGHTFORWARD
DEBATE ON THE SHOW.
AMERICANS HAVE BEEN TALKING TO
THEIR DIFFERENCES FOR MANY YEARS
AND IT'S WORKED PRETTY WELL.
WE FEEL THAT WE HAVE WISER
DECISIONS WHEN BOTH SIDES GET TO
HAVE THEIR SAY.
BUT TONIGHT, WE WILL PAUSE FOR A
MINUTE.
WE WILL INVITE GUESTS ON LATER
IN THE HOUR BUT FIRST THOUGH
IT'S WORTH IT TO CONSIDER
LEARNING WHAT WE'VE LEARNED FROM
BRETT KAVANAUGH'S CONSIDERATION
FOR SUPREME COURT.
IT FEELS LIKE A TURNING POINT,
SOMETHING NEW IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE CERTAINLY HAD CONTROVERSIAL
DEBATES.
ROBERT BORK, CLARENCE THOMAS AND
MANY OTHERS.
SHORTLY AFTER BEING ELECTED
PRESIDENT IN 1936,
FRANKLIN ROOSEVELT TRIED TO TAKE
OVER THE ENTIRE JUDICIAL BRANCH
OF GOVERNMENT SO HE COULD IMPOSE
HIS PROGRAM ON CONGRESS BY
FORCE.
THANKFULLY FDR FAILED IN THAT.
THE POINT IS, POLITICS HAS
ALWAYS INTRUDED ON OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
CONGRESS CONFIRMS THE NOMINEE IS
SO INHERENTLY POLITICAL.
YET SOME OF THIS WE HAVE NOT
SEEN BEFORE.
IT IS ENTIRELY NEW.
NEVER IN OUR LIFETIMES HAVE
SITTING MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
ATTACKED OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM AS
THEY NOW ARE.
LAWMAKERS HAVEN'T NOT MOCKED THE
IDEA OF DUE PROCESS WERE CALLED
FOR THE COLLECTIVE PUNISHMENT OR
DECLARED TO THE BURDEN OF PROOF
IS ON THE ACCUSED RATHER THAN
THE ACCUSER.
ALL OF THAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW IN WASHINGTON AND MORE.
IT'S NOT JUST BRETT KAVANAUGH
UNDER ASSAULT, ELECTED OFFICIALS
HAVE ANNOUNCED THEY NO LONGER
BELIEVE IN OUR WESTERN
UNDERSTANDING OF JUSTICE.
IT IS NO PRESIDENT OF THAT HERE,
IT'S STUNNING.
YOU SHOULD PAY CLOSE ATTENTION
TO WHAT IS HAPPENING BECAUSE IT
COULD AFFECT ALL OF US.
THIS SHIFT BEGAN LATE LAST WEEK
WITH THESE REMARKS FROM THE
HAWAII SENATOR.
>> I JUST WANT TO SAY TO THE MEN
OF THIS COUNTRY, SHUT UP AND
STEP UP, DO THE RIGHT THING FOR
A CHANGE.
NOT ONLY DO WOMEN LIKE DR. FORD
WHO BRAVELY COMES FORWARD NEED
TO BE HEARD, BUT THEY NEED TO BE
BELIEVED.
BE ONE SO THERE YOU HAVE IT, ALL
MEN ARE TO BELIEVED, NOT BECAUSE
THEY ARE PROVED GUILTY BUT
BECAUSE THEY ARE MEN AND THEY
ARE INHERENTLY GUILTY BY THEIR
NATURE.
ALL WOMEN ARE TO BE BELIEVE IT'S
BECAUSE THEY ARE FEMALE, AND ALL
THAT MATTERS IS DNA.
ALL OF US ARE CONDEMNED OR
REDEEMED AT BIRTH AND THERE IS
NOTHING ANY OF US CAN DO TO
CHANGE THAT, IT'S BAKED IN THE
CAKE.
THAT'S WHAT SHE SAID.
NO LIVING U.S. SENATOR HAS EVER
INSIDE ANYTHING LIKE THAT IN
PUBLIC BUT NONE OF THOSE
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES WERE
SPOILED OR WRONG.
SHE KEPT GOING AND HE OR SHE IS
FROM OVER THE WEEKEND.
>> DOESN'T KAVANAUGH HAVE THE
SAME PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE AS
EVERYONE ELSE IN AMERICA?
>> I PUT HIS DENIAL IN THE
CONTEXT OF EVERYTHING THAT I
KNOW ABOUT HIM IN TERMS OF HOW
HE PURCHASES CASES.
>> GIVE HER CREDIT FOR
DIRECTNESS.
BRETT KAVANAUGH IS NOT PROTECTED
BY THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION.
HE DOES NOT ENJOY THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
KAVANAUGH IS GUILTY BECAUSE HIS
OPPONENTS SAY HE IS GUILTY AND
THAT IS HER POSITION.
SHE'S PROUD OF IT AND SHE HAS
BECOME A FOLK HERO ON THE LEFT
FOR SAYING THAT.
WATCH OR SAY IT AGAIN FROM
EARLIER TODAY.
>> CAN YOU CLARIFY WHAT YOU
MEANT?
DO YOU BELIEVE JUDGE KAVANAUGH
DESERVES PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE, OR NOT?
>> WE ARE NOT IN A COURT OF LAW,
WE ARE ACTUALLY IN A COURT OF
CREDIBILITY AT THIS POINT AND
WITHOUT HAVING THE FBI REPORT OR
SOME SEMBLANCE OF TRYING TO GET
CORROBORATION, WE ARE LEFT WITH
THE CREDIBILITY OF THE TWO
WITNESSES.
>> Tucker: OH, A COURT OF
CREDIBILITY.
SHE DIDN'T EXPLAIN WHAT THE
COURT OF CREDIBILITY IS, BUT YOU
CAN BE ASSURED THAT YOU NEVER
WANT TO BE TRIED IN ONE.
IF THE BILL OF RIGHTS DOESN'T
APPLY TO BRETT KAVANAUGH, IT
PROBABLY DOESN'T APPLY TO YOU
EITHER.
IT ALL DEPENDS ON WHAT MAZIE
HIRONO THINKS OF YOUR POLITICAL
VIEWS.
KEEP IN MIND THAT ONCE YOU'VE
BEEN ACCUSED IN THIS NEW COURT
OF CREDIBILITY YOU ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVING YOURSELF
INNOCENT.
IT'S YOUR JOB TO UNCONVICT
YOURSELF.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A MIRROR IMAGE
OF OUR ACTUAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
YOU ARE RIGHT, IT IS.
FOR MORE THAN A THOUSAND YEARS,
THE BURDEN OF PROOF HAS FALLEN
ON THE ACCUSER WHICH IN OUR
COUNTRY AS A GOVERNMENT.
IF THEY SAY YOU DID IT, YOU HAVE
TO PROVE THAT YOU HAVE DONE IT.
HERE IS SENATOR BLUMENTHAL AND
EXPLAINING HOW THE NEW SYSTEM
WORKS.
>> WE HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THESE
ALLEGATIONS.
THEY ARE SERIOUS AND CREDIBLE
AND IT NOW THE PERSON WITH THE
MOST KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THEM,
NAMELY JUDGE BRETT KAVANAUGH, AS
A RESPONSIBILITY, AS EVIDENCE TO
REVIVE THEM.
>> Tucker: YOUR JOB IS TO SHOW
YOU ARE INNOCENT.
SENATOR BLUMENTHAL WENT TO YALE
LAW SCHOOL, THAT HE LEARNED THAT
IN HIS CLASSES THERE?
IT'S A NEW IDEA BUT ALSO A VERY
OLD IDEA WHICH WAS COMMON FOR
THE ACCUSED HAD A RESPONSIBILITY
TO COME FORWARD TO ABOUT THE
CHARGES AGAINST THEM.
HERETICS WHO SURVIVE TORTURE
SOMETIMES GOT DECLARED INNOCENT,
BUT THERE IS A FLIP SIDE TO THE
NEW SYSTEM.
BECAUSE THE ACCUSER GUILTY BY
DEFINITION, THE ACCUSER SUDDENLY
HAS NO RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE
CREDIBLE CLAIMS.
WE ARE SEEING THAT PRINCIPLE IN
ACTION, TOO.
WE COVERED THE STORY ALL LAST
WEEK.
FIVE NIGHTS IN A ROW WE SAID WE
ARE GIVING CHRISTINE FORD EVERY
BENEFIT OF EVERY DOUBT.
AND WE DID THAT.
BUT LET'S BE HONEST NOW.
NOT MANY OF HER CLAIMS WOULD
HOLD UP IN AN ACTUAL COURT, THE
ONE GOVERNED BY THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM THAT WE THOUGHT WE HAD
UNTIL ABOUT TEN DAYS AGO WHEN
MAZIE HIRONO INFORMED US
OTHERWISE.
WHEN DID THIS TAKE PLACE?
SHE DOESN'T KNOW.
WHERE ARE THE WITNESSES TO THIS?
THERE AREN'T ANY.
WHEN WAS THIS FIRST REPORTED TO
AUTHORITIES?
IT NEVER REALLY WAS.
THE STORY CAME OUT IN STAGES AND
IT WAS A RECOVERED MEMORY.
APPARENTLY SOMEONE BY A
PSYCHOTHERAPIST 30 YEARS AFTER
THE FACT.
AND THEN IT WAS UNDER SIX YEARS
BEFORE FORD NAMED BRETT
KAVANAUGH SPECIFICALLY WHEN HE
WAS BEING NOMINATED FOR THE
SUPREME COURT.
THAT WAS THE POSITION AFFORDS A
LAWYER ALL OF WHOM WHO DOUBLED
AS THE DEMOCRATIC ACTIVISTS AND
OPERATIVES, AND SOME OF WHOM
IDENTIFIED BILL CLINTON FROM FAR
GRAVER ASSAULTS THAT HE WAS
ACCUSED OF.
LAST WEEK FOR EXAMPLE, FOR TOLD
SENATORS THAT SHE COULDN'T COME
TO WASHINGTON TO TESTIFY BECAUSE
SHE WAS AFRAID TO FLY ON
AIRPLANES.
THIS FEAR IS A DIRECT RESULT OF
BEING GROPED OVER THE CLOSE BY
BRETT KAVANAUGH IN HIGH SCHOOL
IN THE 80s.
AS ONE OF HER FRIENDS TOLD
"THE WASHINGTON POST," AIRPLANE
CABINS REMIND FORD OF THE
TRAUMA, THEY ARE AN ENCLOSED
SPACE WHERE YOU CAN'T GET AWAY.
BUT IS THIS TRUE?
FORD HAS RELATIVES ON THE
EAST COAST.
ACCORDING TO PUBLISHED ACCOUNTS,
SHE'S BEEN HERE RECENTLY.
DID SHE DRIVE BACK AND FORTH
EVERY TIME SHE VISITED?
WE DON'T KNOW.
THEN "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTED THAT FORD DID GRADUATE
WORK AND, IN IT THAT IS IN ORDER
TO DELAY THE PROCEEDINGS AND
THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT
COMMITTEE WOULD ASK HER IF SHE
SHOWED UP ON THURSDAY.
THEY PROBABLY WON'T ASK HER
THOUGH, THAT WOULD BE A VICTIM'S
SHAMING.
SHE'S A WOMAN AND SHE'S TELLING
THE TRUTH NO MATTER WHAT SHE
SAYS EVEN WHEN THINGS SHE SAYS
TURN OUT TO BE NOT TRUE, THEY
ARE STILL TRUE BY DEFINITION.
WATCH FORMER MICHIGAN
GOVERNOR JENNIFER GRANHOLM
EXPLAINED THIS PRINCIPLE.
>> KEVIN OUT JUDGE, SMITH AND
HER FRIEND, LELAND KAISER SAID
THEY DON'T REMEMBER ANYTHING
LIKE THIS EVER HAPPENING.
AND LELAND KAISER SAID SHE
DOESN'T EVEN REMEMBER BEING AT A
PARTY WHERE KAVANAUGH WAS
PRESENT.
>> THAT ACTUALLY CORROBORATES
FORD'S STORY THAT SHE WAS SO
HORRIFIED BY THIS, SHE KIND OF
SNUCK OUT OR SLUNK OUT OF THIS
APARTMENT IN A WAY THAT NO ONE
WOULD KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO COME
BECAUSE SHE WAS SO UTTERLY
MORTIFIED.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU FOLLOWING
THIS AT HOME?
WHEN YOU ARE CORROBORATING
WITNESSES CAN'T CORROBORATE YOUR
STORY, AND THAT CAN BE
CORROBORATED MAY BE EVEN MORE S
SO.
CERTAINLY THE RULES WASHINGTON
WAS APPLYING TO THE NEW YORKER
MAGAZINE DROPPED LAST NIGHT AND
ONE OF CAVANAUGH'S CLASSMATES AT
YALE SAID, DURING A DRUNKEN
PARTY ON CAMPUS, KAVANAUGH
WAGGED HIS GENITALS IN HER FACE.
WHILE THAT SOUNDS AWFUL.
BUT IN THOSE INITIAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH NEW YORK, THE
CHARACTER WAS HESITANT TO
CONFIRM HIS ROLE.
AFTER SIX DAYS OF CONSULTING HER
MEMORIES AND HER ATTORNEY, SHE
FELT CONFIDENT ENOUGH OF HER
RECOLLECTIONS TO REMEMBER THAT
KAVANAUGH HAD EXPOSED HIMSELF AT
A DRUNKEN DORMITORY PARTY.
SO IT TURNS OUT SHE DIDN'T
ACTUALLY REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED.
NONE OF THE PEOPLE SHE SAID WERE
IN THE ROOM REMEMBER WHAT
HAPPENED EITHER.
YET AFTER TALKING TO HER LAWYER
FOR A WEEK SHE SUDDENLY
REMEMBERS IT.
THAT'S ENOUGH FOR CNN.
STRING THEM UP, GUILTY AS
CHARGED, STRING THEM UP.
>> IT CERTAINLY HAS A RING OF
TRUTH TO ME.
THE IDEA THAT IT IS ALL MADE UP
SEEMS PREPOSTEROUS AT THIS
POINT.
>> IT HAS A RING OF TRUTH,
PERFECT.
LET'S HANG HIM.
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT      ON BOTH
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT      ON BOTS
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT      ON BOTD
THAT'S A JOKE AT THIS POINT, AND
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT      ON BOT,
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT THEY ARE
PLAYING ALONG.
NO MATTER HOW FRIVOLOUS ARE
OBVIOUSLY FRAUDULENT THEY ARE.
SENATE REPUBLICANS ARE THE ONES
WHO MADE THE COURT OF PUBLIC
CREDIBILITY POSSIBLE AT THIS
POINT.
HOW MANY MORE PIECES LIKE IT ARE
COMING?
AS MANY AS IT TAKES, NO QUESTION
ABOUT THAT.
WE CAN'T CONTROL THE SENATE
REPUBLICANS OBVIOUSLY, AND A MAN
WHO WAS LITERALLY MARRIED TO
GEORGE W. BUSH'S ASSISTANT CAN
CONFIRM THE SUPREME COURT THAT
NO REPUBLICAN CAN GET CONFIRMED
TO THE SUPREME COURT EVEN WITH
THE REPUBLICAN CONGRESS, EVER.
BUT IT'S WORSE THAN THAT.
THERE IS A MIDTERM ELECTION JUST
WEEKS FROM NOW.
IF YOU ARE REPUBLICAN, HE MAY BE
WONDERING WHY SHOULD I BOTHER TO
VOTE?
YOU BACK TO TRUMP TO YEARS AGO
AND YOUR AND YOUR BROTHER-IN-LAW
FROM BROOKLYN MOCK TO YOU, BUT
YOU DID IT ANYWAY.
BECAUSE YOU WANTED TO SECURE
BORDERS.
HE WANTED AN END TO OBAMACARE
AND HE WANTED NONCRAZY PEOPLE ON
THE SUPREME COURT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
YOU DIDN'T GET THE FIRST TWO AND
YOU ARE STARTING TO REALIZE YOU
PROBABLY NEVER WILL GET THEM.
WE ARE ALL DISCOVERING IT ISN'T
EASY, WHY IS THAT?
THE REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE DO
NOT CARE ABOUT YOU.
THAT'S WHAT YOU DO ABOUT PEOPLE
YOU CARE ABOUT.
IF THE REPUBLICANS CARE TO, THEY
WOULD PROTECT YOU.
THEY WOULD PROTECT YOUR CHILDREN
FROM THE TORRENT OF MANDATORY
PROPAGANDA THEY FACE IN SCHOOLS
THAT ARE BANKRUPTING THEM.
THEY PROTECT YOUR PRIVACY AND
FREEDOM OF SPEECH, FREEDOM OF
WORSHIP FROM THE TECH MONOPOLIES
THAT SEEM TO CRUSH ALL OF THOSE
THINGS AND THEY PROTECT BRETT
KAVANAUGH FROM THE OBVIOUS
SMEARS THAT ARE DESTROYING HIS
FAMILY IN HIS LIFE.
THEY WON'T PROTECT HIM AND THEY
WON'T PROTECT HIM FOR THE SAME
REASONS THEY WON'T PROTECT YOU,
AND IT'S HARD AND EMBARRASSING.